ارى مشاركه كبيره من النساء والشباب وان
تكون نسبه المشاركه فوق 90 بالمئه باعث
على السعاده ايضا فان اردوغان رغم
افتراءاته واهانته لم يستطع الحصول على
النتيجه
المرجوه لديها لا احد
يحاول ان يدعي الفوز والفوز لا يتحقق من
خلال الشرب واذا قال الشعب نعم للجوله
الثانيه على الرحب والسعاده ولكننا سننتصر
في الجوله الاولى مطلقا
وان النتائج المؤقته قد كشفت مره اخرى ان
اردوغان لم يستطع ان ينال الثقه المطلوبه
من الشعب لان الثقه مره فوق خمسين بالمئه
وان تراجع اصوات حزب العداله والتنميه
الدليل على ذلك ونحن من اجل تركي
خلال الولايات القادمه
وسنبذل قصار جهدنا وسنناضل من اجل تحقيق
الحريات والعداله لهذا الشعب والشعب
فليتاكد نحن سننتصر وسننتصر مطلقا وسنحقق
الديمقراطيه فالشكر موصول اليكم جميعا